-It´s always
such a delight to see you.
-Yes.
-We met in 2004...
-Yes, we did.
-...on the set of a film
that not a lot of people have
seen, called "See This Movie."
Ironically called
"See This Movie."
-"See This Movie."
-Where we played film --
Look at the --
Look how young we are.
Couple of young film students.
-Look at all the hope.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This movie was so long ago,
pictures were blurry.
-Yeah, they really were.
-Yeah, yeah.
That´s before HD.
-And that´s John Cho
right there.
-And John Cho, yeah.
The great John Cho
in the middle.
-Yeah.
-I also --
We´re working on
a show together.
You´re doing the hard work.
-Yes.
-You´re a cast member
on a new show called "A.P. Bio."
that´s gonna be
on NBC in February.
-Yeah.
-And you were here --
Yeah, give it up for a show
you haven´t seen.
-Yeah, it´s...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Give it up for a show
that has yet to be scheduled.
-We could´ve just made that up.
But, yeah, applaud.
-That was a test.
-Yeah. Why not?
-But you came out --
There´s a thing called upfronts.
That´s where
we saw each other last.
-The last --
And I´d never done upfronts.
Upfronts is where you come
and you talk to affiliates
and press about the show.
And I did not know
that it was a morn--
it was a dawn-till-dusk,
just nonstop gab fest
where you´re basically
selling your product.
So I didn´t see you that day
till the end of the night
at that restaurant
where we all got together.
And so when I --
And I was so happy to see you,
but I had so been stuck in my
head, in selling the show mode
that our conversation --
I was so afraid afterward.
Like, "He thinks I´m psychotic."
Because you were --
It was like,
"Hey, man, good to see you."
"It´s great to see you, Seth.
And this restaurant
is fantastic.
The food here is so..."
[ Laughter ]
I don´t even remember
what I said.
It was just in that weird
non-human way of --
It was like
I was trying to sell you
on the wonder
of hanging out with me.
Even though
we were already hanging out.
It was the saddest --
-That was not my take on it.
-No.
Okay, good, good.
My God.
-You and your co-star,
Glenn Howerton
were on the red carpet.
-Yeah.
-I remember us talking
about this at the dinner.
Because E! was talk--
They were interviewing people
about the 10th anniversary
of the Kardashians.
-Yes they were.
-And you guys
have a new show on NBC.
So new --
You´re new to the network.
You did not realize
that E! and NBC
are owned by the same company.
-No idea.
And so we´re going down
the carpet and talking,
and then E! says, "Hey,
can we get your thoughts
on the 10th-year anniversary
of ´Keeping Up
With the Kardashians´?"
And Glenn said,
"I would rather cut my scrotum
off with a razor blade."
[ Laughter ]
And this is on camera.
Like they´re talking --
"Oh, well, I mean, uh...
You know, it´s -- You´re both
kind of on the same network."
And you could see Glenn´s face
realizing what he had just done.
And then he --
Like, you could hear the gears
grinding of him going,
"But 10 years is impressive,
whether or not
I want to talk about it."
It was the --
And I am beside him, like,
just trying -- it was the --
maybe the worst save
I´ve ever seen.
-Yeah.
-But it was beautiful.
It was one of the best --
Oh, I loved it so much.
So funny.
-So congratulations
on your special, "Annihilation."
-Thank you.
-Obviously, we saw in the clip,
it´s a little bit about,
you know,
the world we´re living in now.
But you also had
an incredibly difficult year.
Your wife passed away.
And you talk about that
at length.
Certainly, my condolences,
our condolences.
The title -- was that --
Was it hard to pick the title,
or was it...?
-You know, I didn´t really --
I didn´t really come up
with the title
until I was a week away
from doing the special.
Because that´s how it felt to me
at that point,
in terms of the world,
how if the world
had been annihilated,
and then in talking about
what I´d gone through,
I was taken back emotionally
to April of 2016,
and that was where I felt like
I had been annihilated.
There were months
where I wasn´t even sure
if I was alive, basically.
And then, so, as a --
almost as a joke
on top of those
two very dark concepts was --
You know, the comedian speak of
"Oh, I killed, I annihilated."
So I was like, "Okay.
I´ll put that in there
almost as an ironic..."
Because I was so terrified of
"What if I go out
and tape this special
and it just bombs horribly
and I´m not able
to make this stuff funny?"
And so I just --
I almost put that in there
as a reverse good-luck charm,
maybe?
-Yeah.
-If that make sense.
-Obviously, you know,
for people who don´t know,
when you do a special,
you´re working that material
for so long, so many nights.
-Yes.
-Not only obviously
you´re working towards
having a product that
you´re proud to show people.
Was it incredibly cathartic for
you to go through that process
of talking
about this thing onstage?
-Yeah, once I actually
got onstage --
It was horrible, the hours
and minutes leading up to it.
It got to the point
where I´m like,
"Just let me go out there
and tape this,"
because the tension
was killing me.
And then, once I got out there
and it started going,
and when you do a special,
if you´ve really worked it,
the special takes over,
and it´s almost like
you ride the material itself.
That sounds very hippie-esque.
I´m sorry about that.
[ Laughter ]
You know what you do, man?
You catch a laughter wave.
[ Laughter ]
And you get on your --
you get on your --
get on your smile surfboard.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And you know what you do?
You ride it into chuckle beach.
That´s what I...
[ Laughter and applause ]
No, but, like, you know --
But I didn´t know,
´cause I was so in my own head.
Even doing it, I´m like,
"What if I don´t --
What if the stuff
doesn´t take over?"
But it did.
It´s like, "This is what I do,"
and it was this very --
It was almost like
the life force asserting itself,
going, "Yes, you´ve gone
through all of this hell,
but you´re still a comedian,
and this is what you do."
And just that felt
really amazing to me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It´s wonderful.